three years ago you probably only heard
skepticism of the covid regime on this
show maybe a handful of others maybe
from your crazy conservative Uncle
within the last year or so you may have
heard covid skepticism from your center
right or maybe even center-left friends
now you are hearing it during the
opening monologue on Saturday Night Live
this country seems so divided beautiful
ugly black white blue red I love
everybody maybe because I'm a redneck
hippie uh you know the red in me thinks
you should be allowed to own guns the
blue in me thinks squirt guns
so I'm red and blue which makes purple
so the movie goes like this
the biggest drug cartels in the world
get together and buy up all the media
and all the politicians and force all
the people in the world stay locked in
their homes and people can only come out
if they take the cartels drugs and keep
taking them over and over
I threw the script away I mean who is
going to believe that crazy idea being
forced to do drugs I do that voluntarily
all day long
anyway
my favorite part of Woody Harrelson's
bit which is broadly this long drug joke
but within it is this brutal joke about
how covid was just completely insane and
bogus my favorite part was the audience
reaction
because it later on they laughed but in
that little covid bit they're almost
totally silent
liberal New Yorkers were trained for
three years to take kovid super duper
seriously now it's being presented to
them as a joke
some of us knew from the beginning that
pretty much the whole thing was bogus
but they did not and now we're finding
out that the so-called conspiracy
theorists were right all along that fact
is so obvious that they are now joking
about it on Saturday Night Live
the ruling Elites screwed up our lives
over nothing and in the audience's
defense it's tough to accept that
something we believe to be so serious
was in fact a joke and the joke of
course was on all of us I'm Michael
Knowles this the Michael Knowles show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from the darson who
says the greatest trick that devil ever
pulled was making women think their
luggage never existed you know almost I
would say that was the greatest trick
that a sort of minor demon pulled so
maybe who worked in the Biden
Administration but not not The Devil
Himself just one of those sort of lesser
lesser demons Devils running around out
there when you want to stay alert and I
recommend you do especially when you're
going through the airport then you got
to check out Black Rifle coffee right
now go to Black riflecoffee.com use
promo code Knowles Black Rifle coffee is
fueling Americans before they go out to
do epic things with their lives led by a
team of military veterans the guys at
Black Rifle coffee are hyper focused and
Hyper Vigilant in everything they do
lucky for you they're obsessed with
making great coffee because every great
adventure starts with a great cup of
coffee they serve great coffee to folks
who love America and that's the start
and end of it more than just making
great coffee Black Rifle coffee's
missionary goal is to give back to
Americans who've fought and are fighting
for freedom in this country they want to
sell enough premium coffee to be able to
build a support network for veterans
First Responders and law enforcement if
you want to support this incredible
company go to blackriflecoffee.com use
promo code Knolls a checkout for 10 off
your purchase
and your first coffee Club order the
coffee is one of a kind
it's your support that gets gear funding
and supplies into the hands of those on
our front lines go to Black
riflecoffee.com use promo code Knowles
kwles for 10 off you can also find Black
Rifle coffee in grocery and convenience
stores near you Black Rifle coffee
America's coffee
I loved Woody Harrelson's bit you see
how he sets it up there he's he's giving
himself Runway with the audience which
is much more liberal than he is but
Woody Harrelson has cred on both sides
of the aisle because as he says he's a
redneck hippie
so he's kind of a right winger he's kind
of a left Winger
Woody Harrelson is in many ways
your average voter
that's why it matters that Woody
Harrelson is making jokes about covid
now
I think this is insane the drug
companies
they have so much control over the media
so much control over the government they
get special legal protections they lock
us all up and say the only way you can
leave your house is if you take our drug
again and again and again that's kind of
crazy isn't it
people like Woody Harrelson or Joe Rogan
or Elon Musk or people who are they're
not right Wingers exactly but they're
not leftist liberals they're just they
represent I think
the average voter and so when the libs
lose those guys that is really really
dangerous for them in the elections why
do people joke about this now the reason
that people are joking about kovid is
because
another government agency just concluded
that a lot of what we were told about
covid was fake the energy Department
with its network of U.S National
Laboratories just revised its assessment
to say with low confidence but
nevertheless they're saying this that
the pandemic very likely began with a
lab leak remember the first story we
told was was that the pandemic began
with a bad batch of bat soup at a Wuhan
wet Market that just coincidentally was
right down the street from a bio lab but
pay no attention to that that's a crazy
conspiracy theory
already we've got the National
Intelligence Council and four agencies
for other agencies that the Wall Street
Journal refuses to identify still
believes with low confidence in the
natural emergence Theory the Wuhan wet
Market Theory the FBI said two years ago
now with moderate confidence that it
probably began with the lab League the
CIA and two other agencies still have
not quite made a determination but
I think we see which way this is
trending
okay that
that conspiracy theory that some people
were talking about in 2020
every single day that goes by seems to
seem less Fantastical and more and more
correct because as many of us have noted
before the difference between a
conspiracy theory and the truth these
days is about 6 to 12 months
now apoorva mandavili who is a writer
with the New York Times
she tweeted out in 2021 she said someday
we will stop talking about the lab leak
Theory and maybe even admit it's racist
roots
that'll last that day is not yet here
that was two years ago two years later
the theory is almost entirely Vindicated
all the authorities on this are leaning
in that direction
New York Times looks ridiculous as it
always does so we can say good we were
right
we were right watching the Woody
Harrelson monologue we can say oh good
we were right
watching the shift in public opinion
watching the way that people contracted
the virus watching the efficacy of the
masks and the vaccines all the studies
that are coming out now showing that
perhaps the vaccines were not quite so
effective as we were told they were in
fact a major study we talked about last
week showing they weren't effective at
all the vaccine mandates city-wide not
effective at all according to a study
that we also cited last week
so we can say we were right it's not
enough to be right it is not enough to
be right because you know what's going
to happen to a poorva mandevilla at the
New York Times who got the lab League
Theory totally wrong it would seem
nothing's going to happen to her do you
know what's going to happen to the
companies that fired employees for not
taking the fauci auchi for the
government bureaucrats fired people for
not taking that fauci ouchy for the
public officials who lied to us or at
least were incompetent enough to to get
the whole pandemic wrong but who also
lied to us you know what's going to
happen to them probably nothing it's not
enough to be right because we're right
now we've been right in the past we're
always right
but they're just going to pull another
trick in six months or a year
and we're going to be right again and
they're going to be wrong and it's not
going to matter because they're going to
have the power so we have to do is hold
people to account
last year
during the midterm elections I jokingly
suggested something called the Michael
Knowles Public Health protection pledge
and it said that I won't vote for
anybody in a federal election who
doesn't promise to to zero out Dr
fauci's salary and investigate him
and Rand Paul at that same time was
going after Dr fauci pretty hard
representative Paul goes are actually
entered in my public health protection
pledge as a congressional resolution
started to pick up among some candidates
and once the polls started to look as
though the Republicans were going to
retake the house what did Dr fauci say
he said Peace see you later I'm out of
here I don't because even beyond what I
was saying on the podcast even beyond
what Rand Paul was saying on the floor
of the Senate it was pretty clear that
the Republicans had this guy in their
sights and so fauci said Okay I want to
leave and he admitted he was leaving in
part because he thought that would take
some of the political pressure off
they're going to be a lot of Republicans
who say Okay fauci's old news the
pandemic was three years ago let's just
move on don't move on you have to hold
these people for to account if you don't
drag fauci before Congress if you don't
go after him for perjuring himself which
he certainly did if you don't go after
the other people who lied to us about
kovid and screwed up everybody's lives
for three years they're just gonna do it
again you have you can't just say let
bygones be bygones they're already
setting up the stage for the next big
political power grab don't let them get
away with this you've got to teach them
that there are consequences
speaking of holding people to account
wonderful story out of Florida yesterday
which is that they executed a murderer
Governor Ron DeSantis refused to Pardon
this guy his name is Donald dilbeck
career criminal and he was executed this
is a guy
who was convicted of the 1990 murder of
a woman felam van mother in a Tallassee
mall parking lot and he he was only able
to murder her because he had escaped
from prison where he was at the time
serving a life sentence for killing a
sheriff's deputy in 1979. this is a bad
bad dude
now this was the first execution in
Florida in more than three years
it was the 100th execution since the
Supreme Court allowed the practice to
resume in 1975 and Ron DeSantis is going
pretty hard after this he's been he's
been a tough Law and Order kind of
governor and he's saying well if you
kill somebody we're going to kill you
back
the final words of this man Donald
dilbeck are what really to me tell the
whole story
so after the family of the woman that he
murdered wrote they said 11 932 days ago
Donald dilbeck brutally killed our
mother we were robbed of years of
memories with her and it has been very
painful ever since however the execution
has given us some closure we're grateful
to Governor DeSantis for carrying out
the sentence what were the final words
of this murderer he said I know I hurt
people when I was young I really messed
up but I know Ron DeSantis has done a
lot worse he's done a lot worse than
murder two people one of whom was a
mother he's taken a lot from a lot of
people I speak for all men women and
children he's put his foot on our necks
Ron DeSantis and other people like him
can suck our
then he names an appendage which I won't
I won't name those are his final words
Ron DeSantis can suck my
appendage and
conclusion from that is
this guy didn't learn anything
this murderer this double murderer
guy who kills a mother in Cold Blood in
a parking lot
32 and a half years he was in prison he
didn't learn anything
one of the arguments against the death
penalty is we need to give these guys a
time to change their mind to repent to
rehabilitate first of all hanging
concentrates the mind I sometimes think
a shorter time scale to consider
repentance is better than a longer one
but even look at the long one 32 and a
half years wasn't enough to change this
guy's mind those are the final words he
wants to go out on doesn't learn a damn
thing in prison doesn't seem to have any
remorse whatsoever
see you buddy the Civil Authority does
not wield The Sword in vain and people
need to know the public needs to know
that there are consequences to bad
actions this is basic incentives if you
don't punish bad behavior you're going
to get more bad behavior if you don't
reward good behavior then you're less
likely to get more of that good behavior
basic incentives and some of those basic
government incentives include the Noose
or in this case the lethal injection you
too will die someday that's why you need
to check out epic will right now go to
epicwill.com use promo code Knowles
according to a recent poll 62 percent of
Americans who think about their own
death a lot of the time do not have a
will
seems kind of strange doesn't it it's a
little like being afraid your house will
burn down but not having homeowners
insurance or being afraid of drowning
but refusing to wear a life jacket a
will protects your wishes and your
family should something happen to you
when you have one you have peace of mind
because you know you've done your best
to protect the ones you care about I
cannot stress enough how important it is
to write a will an epic will is here to
get you started for just 119 dollars and
in as little as five minutes epic will
can help you create your last will and
testament living will and even
Healthcare power of attorney there's
step-by-step online form makes it super
easy all you've got to do is fill in the
blanks do it now I put off getting my
will for so long and I wouldn't have
known what would happen to my money or
my stuff or most importantly my kids so
now it's squared away go to epicwill.com
be like me use promo code Knowles to
save 10 on Epic Will's complete will
package that's epicwill.com promo code
Knowles
forget for a moment Ron DeSantis who's
done a great job on crime and Law and
Order down in Florida
let's turn it up a notch a little bit
let's take a look down at El Salvador
El Salvador not known for being the
safest place in the world probably not
where you want to go honeymoon and yet
El Salvador has had
it's a miracle political program over
the last couple of years El Salvador's
murder rate has plummeted by 50 percent
El Salvador
with a new a new president president
naib bukili
has had its its murder rate tumble
56.8 percent in 2022 alone
how did El Salvador do that
it wanted to do that it wanted to fix
the murder problem
it mustered the political will to do it
and then the president
affecting this policy
sent in troops to go round up MS-13 like
the animals that they are they just
released a propaganda video it's an
amazing propaganda video
so you see the MS-13 gangsters in this
prison this super max prison you've got
these MS-13 gangsters
they've got their heads down
for they're all crouched over they look
like
insects or they're all tatted up in
green they've got their heads down below
their hands the guards all have black
masks on presumably because the guards
don't want MS-13 to go murder all their
families they're just standing in their
boxer shorts The Reason by the way that
they're shirtless I think is to show
that they're all just tatted up and all
this green some sometimes occult imagery
if demons were incarnate it would be
these guys and yet when they're outside
the clink they look so tough right that
people are encouraged to join these
these types of gangs because they think
it'll it'll get the money and women and
status and yet what the president has
done here is cram them all into this
extremely high security prison round
them up like animals I think he he
rounded up something like 65 000 of
these criminals threw them all in prison
and then he didn't just stop there he
created a very slick highly produced
propaganda video
humiliating them
and then he put that out there for all
the world to see
we need we need to learn from El
Salvador never thought I would say that
sentence but we in the United States
need to follow the lead of the
government of El Salvador
we need to be clear that if you commit
crimes you will be punished for it
there's really basic stuff that we all
used to know one of the arguments
against capital punishment is that it
doesn't actually deter crime
and the studies that suggest it doesn't
actually deter crime or a little bit
suspect but let's take them at face
value let's say it's true that capital
punishment today does not really deter
crime
what would the surprise be there we
don't really carry out capital
punishment the way it's carried out is
completely haphazard most of the time
some lib Governor will just let
everybody off the hook
or some Court will pretend like capital
punishment is cruel and unusual
punishment it's neither
and so even if there is a conviction for
capital punishment it's not going to
disturb crime because people don't
believe that they're actually going to
carry it out
if you had a country right now
where the president
attended a capital punishment let's say
there were capital punishment at the
federal level a federal inmate is going
to be executed and the president not
only didn't grant clemency but showed up
as the face of Justice in America
that would do a lot to deter crime
and what the libs and the squishes would
say is they would say this is
this is cruel this is inhumane this is
authoritarian it's authoritative that's
what they are saying in fact the New
Yorker says the rise of naive bouquilis
Elsa of El Salvador's authoritarian
president oh he's so it's a repressive
Crackdown listen to what they say they
say the budding strong man has written
Bitcoin schemes
and a repressive Crackdown on gangs
to become Latin America's most popular
leader
can you be repressive
against gangs
I guess I guess so I guess you can
repress The Gangs but that seems like
that is actually liberative of the
people it's not repressive on the people
when you when you go after these
criminals when you go after these
gangsters
it represses that group
and it frees the other group
that's why he's Latin America's most
popular leader
it's authoritarian he's wielding
authority to do good to get the bad guys
and to help the good guys we should be
doing that too
I mentioned on the show a week or two
ago I said there are two words you got
to write them down if you're driving
wait until you pull over I don't want
you get in a car accident the two the
two phrases you've got to write down are
big government and authoritarian
those are words that today don't mean
anything
authoritarian is just a word that the
Liberals use when conservatives wield
political power ever
we should be doing that we should do
that a lot more we should take some real
lessons
from naive bouquili I'm sure I'm
mispronouncing his name
what he is showing us is that the law is
a teacher
we've known this all the way back to the
ancient Greeks the law is a teacher
so we on the American right we like to
say politics is Downstream of culture
and that is true to a certain extent the
movies affect the government the way the
way that law is made no question about
it I think daily wire has actually shown
that pretty clearly in the battle over
transgenderism among other battles
but the law also affects politics and
the law is also a teacher
and when the law
sends an army to your door and rounds up
your gang like the animals that they are
you're going to get fewer gangsters and
they're going to commit fewer crimes and
that's going to change the culture and
that's a good thing speaking of the law
as a teacher
great new law in Kansas
has become the first state to pass a
bill that defines woman as someone who
is biologically born female
that's it that's what a woman is
which means that this will ban men who
identify as transgender women from using
single sex areas designated for women
it's called the women's Bill of Rights
it was approved by legislators 26 to 10
on Thursday only Republicans support
there
and the bill defines a female as someone
quote whose biological reproductive
system is developed to produce OVA while
male refers to anyone whose reproductive
system quote is developed to fertilize
the OVA of a female this is a beautiful
bill because
it it doesn't just say don't trans the
kids
it doesn't just say wait till eight
to introduce kids to transgenderism in
schools once they turn nine that's fine
it doesn't just say only miners can't
it's it bans transgenderism for all
practical purposes in the state for
everybody and it has to
in order for women to have the right to
have their own bathrooms you have to ban
transgenderism entirely you can't just
ban it for the kids it's got to be
entirely in order for women to be able
to have their own locker rooms at the
gym you have to ban transgenderism
entirely
in order to protect businesses from
having to participate in weird occult
sexual rituals like the transgender
transition you have to ban
transgenderism
entirely
I love this bill because it is so much
more aggressive than the other bills
we've seen the other I don't mean to
knock the other governors in the other
state houses they've done a great job
laying the fan work the groundwork
rather but this bill goes much further
and it reminds us of a
truth in politics that Republicans all
too often forget
you're either on offense or you're on
defense
you're either making gains in the
culture or you're losing ground in the
culture there's no standing still
there's no status quo there's no
neutrality and what the conservatives
have screwed up on for at least 50 years
now probably more is the libs make some
crazy aggressive play and then we try to
dial it back by about five to ten
percent
or Worse we try to slow it down
by about five to ten percent
so the libs attack the family through
feminism
the fundamental political institution
they claim that men and women are
basically the same
that takes the culture pretty far to the
left and then conservatives try to they
try to inch it back a little bit but not
by the by the time they're even thinking
about inching it back the libs push
forward with the normalization of other
sexual practices gay rights among other
things and then by the time the
conservatives are trying to dial that
back the lives of they've lurched much
further to the left they're trying to
redefine marriage now let's say redefine
marriage well I don't know I guess we
could come to some kind of terms with a
civil union and by the time you say that
they've lurched even further to left now
they're saying actually we've got
transgenderism actually now a man can
become a woman a man can become a woman
okay but but maybe we shouldn't do it to
my by the time we say that oh my gosh
we're now we're all the way off the
screen because now they're trying to
trans the kids and there are many
conservatives now who are saying look if
you want if you're a man and you want to
put on a dress that's fine but just
don't do it to children just don't make
me pay for it
no the the only way even to stop there
even if all you want to do is stop where
we are right now the only way to do that
is to push so aggressively in the other
direction that you're trying to take
background that we seated
years ago decades ago Kansas absolutely
leading the way love it we got to hire
some of those people we need to hire
those Kansas politicians for the
national Republican party when you want
to hire people you got to check out zip
recruiter right now go to
ziprecruiter.com Knowles really really
important to get good people for your
company okay Personnel is policy it's
the most important investment you're
going to make in your company ZIP
recruiters matching technology excels at
finding the most qualified candidates
for a wide range of roles if you're
hiring you can quickly find the right
person head on over to ziprecruiter.com
Knowles try it for free ZIP recruiter
uses powerful technology to find the
right candidates for your job you see a
candidate you like you can easily send
them a personal invite so they're more
likely to apply their user friendly
dashboard makes it easy to filter review
and rate your candidates all from one
place let ZipRecruiter help you find the
best people for all your roles four out
of five employers who post on
ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day see for yourself at
ziprecruiter.com Knowles to try for free
that is ziprecruiter.com com slash
k-n-o-w-l-e-s do not hesitate one more
second get the very best people for your
role zip recruiter the smartest way to
hire
the only way that we are going to score
cultural wins and take that cultural
ground is to punish the people
who have
who have upended our culture so
I think the broad theme of today's show
punishment I'm the Punisher Michael The
Punisher Knowles over here looking to
Rhonda santis and the president of El
Salvador and the state house in Kansas
to lead the way forward for the nation
looking also to Chloe Cole Chloe Cole is
a detransitioned 18 year old woman
she has just announced the first
official lawsuit in the United States
against the hospital and Affiliated
Medical Group that facilitated her
medical transition as a minor absolutely
great news we saw a story similar to
this about a couple of weeks ago in
Canada the first transgender
detransition person sued her doctors in
Canada
for transitioning her I thought it was
great at the time I said we need this in
the United States now we're seeing it
the center for American Liberty along
with the Dillon Law Group you know our
friend Harmony Dillon and lemandri and
Jonah LLP have filed lawsuit against the
Permanente Medical Group
the Kaiser Foundation Health Plan and
Kaiser Foundation hospitals
alleging medical negligence
that's the charge here
a kid goes up says hey I know I'm a girl
but I say that I'm a boy now and
therefore I want you to pump me full of
chemicals and mutilate me
doctors if they are following the
Hippocratic oath and acting in a way
that is medically responsible will say
Oh no you're not no you're not let's get
you some
doctors who are negligent and perverse
and incompetent or worse
they will say oh yeah I guess you're
right yeah you're a man and
coincidentally we're going to recommend
surgeries and drugs that are very very
expensive and that you're going to be
hooked on for the rest of your life okay
get her over to the operating table
that's that's medical negligence I know
that some conservatives are going to say
well it's the it's the individual's
fault for for demanding this
or in the case of minors well it's the
parents fault for taking the the
children to these hospitals though
increasingly the parents don't have much
say over it the state is coming in and
enforcing these kinds of procedures
but it's the doctor's fault too the
doctors should not be performing these
surgeries and they should be held to
account they should lose their licenses
they should lose a lot of money
as hermit put it Chloe's family sought
medical treatment for her at Kaiser her
Physicians and other medical
professionals violated the first Norm of
the profession the Hippocratic Oath when
instead of caring for her and providing
medically competent diagnoses and
treatment they permanently disfigured
her for-profit for a pretty high profit
because
with
it's not cheap but it's not that
expensive
or telling a young person to maybe go
you know maybe try to sort things out
these are probably as well
they don't make any money on that
but but sending someone to get some of
the most expensive treatments on Earth
for the rest of their lives that does
make a profit I think it's a great angle
to focus on and I think every other D
transitioner who has experienced even
the slightest Pang of regret should sue
these people into the dirt speaking of
holding Bad actors to account
Joe Biden is facing a lot of criticism
because the president refuses to go to
East Palestine Ohio he was finally asked
about this on ABC News and the president
said
not only is he not going to go to East
Palestine he doesn't even really
remember who he's talked to over there
it's been three weeks now since the
toxic train derailment in East Palestine
Ohio as you know the mayor says he saw
you in Ukraine and he says it tells you
he doesn't care about us and they're
asking is the President coming to Ohio
do you have any plan to travel to Ohio
and have you talked with the mayor yet
let's put this in perspective within two
hours
of that derailment the EPA was in there
within two hours
every major agency in the United States
government has had anything to do with
Rail and or cleanup was there and is
there so do you plan to travel there and
have you talked with the mayor I I can't
recall that I don't think I've talked to
the mayor I talked to everyone else
there and I'm multiple times talked to
both the Senators but both Governors
I've talked to everyone there's a talk
to and we made it clear that everything
is available
yeah but are you gonna go why won't you
answer that question
credit to David Muir here he's he asks
are you going to go to East Palestine
months as well now listen here come on
now Jack
come on you're gonna go get some mint
chocolate chip take a swim down by the
pool 23 skadoo Jack this is okay
um but are you gonna go to East
Palestine uh listen here fat I I'm
talking to senators and I come on and
and I said I I said back when I was in
the swimming pool back in Scranton I
Mr President hello Mr President you're
gonna answer you're not gonna answer
because the answer is no
he is not going to go to East Palestine
as of today and do you know why he can't
go
it's not just that he's lazy it's not
just that he doesn't like the people in
Ohio it's not just that he thinks
they're deplorable irredeemable flyover
people
he can't go because Trump went
can't go
because if he goes he's going to look so
weak he's going to look like Trump
bullied him into going he can't go
because he knows the people in East
Palestine like Trump they don't like
Biden the people in East Palestine are
Republicans by and large not Democrats
and even Beyond partisanship the people
of East Palestine rightly observe that
the current President Joe Biden doesn't
give a damn about them and Trump
actually does seem to care you can see
it it was the first moment of Trump's
campaign where I thought man he might be
getting his mojo back this is what I
want to see from Trump campaigns I'm
going to East Palestine eating
McDonald's with people
making fun of Joe Biden forcing Joe
Biden to to at least address the issue
saying where are you Joe why won't you
come down that's the guy that's the guy
that you're going to want to vote for
another example I know people always
doubt Trump's political strategy I I've
thought that Trump is a pretty good
political strategist my evidence for
this is the man won the highest office
in the land the first time he ever
officially ran for it he kind of teased
a campaign in 2000 but the first time he
really ran uh he didn't win May or he
didn't win Congressman he didn't win
Senator he won the highest office in the
land the guy probably knows a thing or
two about politics
and the strategy here was really really
smart or at least even if it wasn't
conscious the effect of it is really
really smart
right now Biden is in a lose-lose he's
damned if he does damn it if he doesn't
if he goes to East Palestine he looks
like a jerk if he doesn't go to East
Palestine he looks like a jerk and the
reason for that is he is a jerk so it's
a good strategy because it shows us the
truth now what is the federal government
doing with regard to East Palestine the
federal government finally
has ordered a halt
to the cleanup because you know how you
know how this Administration works
the the administration allows problems
to Fester
not just on Transportation but on crime
on immigration on International Affairs
on everything they just allow problems
to fester and they get really really bad
and then you get some catastrophic event
like you saw with the train derailment
in Ohio and then even if you don't want
to blame the administration and say it's
entirely their fault for how the Train
derailed okay that's fine it's not
entirely their fault but then what
happens
the cleanup
starts to create even more problems
there were questions raised about why
did why did Norfolk Southern have to
burn off all of those toxic chemicals
and send a mushroom cloud of poison into
the air well they said because one of
the cars might have exploded
there was a problem with one of the cars
okay
why did you burn off the chemicals in
five cars
well you know there was a problem in a
second car okay but there weren't
problems in all of these cars and so in
some cases couldn't you have contained
the chemicals did you have to burn all
of them off
polluting the air giving the residents
of East Palestine all sorts of terrible
rashes and coughs and and ailments
apparently compromising the drinking
water it remains unclear how compromised
that drinking water is but a lot of the
water intake facilities nearby are
turning off
East Palestine they say no we don't want
any water that's anywhere near East
Palestine they don't trust the water
there
and now what about all the poisoned dirt
what about all of the debris from this
derailment where is it going
well apparently it's been going all over
the place
officials in in Texas and Michigan
have said that they are now receiving
the debris from the derailment and
they're getting tainted soil and they're
getting tainted water millions of
gallons of water used to douse Fires at
that site have been brought into their
states without full disclosure so they
wake up one day in Texas and Michigan
they say wait why are you sending your
poison over here federal government how
is it that you can take a bad situation
and just make it worse by the day
and have no accountability for it at all
Ohio officials say that 20 truckloads of
contaminated soil have been hauled away
from the site some 15 truckloads were
taken to a licensed Hazardous Waste
Facility in Belleville Michigan the five
were then sent back to East Palestine
what is this all about why is this so
incompetent and why was it all burned
off I don't want to sound like a crazy
conspiracy theorist but given
given how conspiracy theories have been
basically
almost all of them Vindicated in the
last three years I guess we have to
entertain them I told you I'm not a
conspiracy theorist I am a coincidence
noticer I have to ask
is is maybe
one of the potential explanations for
the massive burnoff of chemicals that
many experts have said was imprudent and
unnecessary is maybe one of the
explanations for Norfolk Southern just
secretly hauling off without full
disclosure that the waste these other
places
or they may be covering something up
is there something here that we haven't
quite seen so I'm glad to see the EPA
finally has come down and said hey we're
going to Halt this we're going to Halt
this cleanup until we can figure out
what the hell is going on wish that they
would have figured that one out three
weeks ago
it just seems like this Administration
is always a day late and a dollar short
it's your last chance to celebrate
President's Day this year take advantage
before it's too late with the daily
wires our president's for sale sale with
40 off memberships the big guy got ten
percent we're giving you 40 get access
to the world of daily wire plus with
Fearless documentaries gripping movies
Dennis prager's master's program and the
entire library of Dr Jordan Peterson's
work including new productions Exodus
logos and literacy on marriage all
available to watch right now coming down
the pipeline to a TV or a laptop near
you new episodes of Ben Shapiro's the
search Exodus part 2 are much
anticipated DW kids content and
Pendragon later this year
we're also giving you up to 40 of select
items in the daily wire shop last chance
to take advantage of our presidents for
sale sale today go to dailywire.com
subscribe to become a member today
dailywire.com subscribe
speaking of Joe Biden covering things up
Joe Biden's got another Scandal on his
hands which is that shortly after
haranguing Donald Trump for allegedly
holding classified documents improperly
at his home Joe Biden was discovered to
be improperly holding classified
documents at his home at one of his
offices documents dating back not just
to his presidency when he would have had
the authority to declassify the
documents but to his vice presidency
potentially to his Senate days guys got
classified documents everywhere
apparently left some of them in a box
next to his Corvette that his degenerate
son was driving oh that's good Hunter
Biden who makes pretty much all of his
money on corruption and specifically
corruption selling his father's
influence to foreign actors in Ukraine
and in China when when Joe Biden was
vice president yeah that guy just was
just tooling around in the vet right
next to all those classified documents
so Joe Biden was just asked about this
also by David Muir on ABC News
he was asked what's the difference
between what Trump did and what you did
here's the answer
but I do remember something you said
after the Discovery at Mar-A-Lago you
said I thought data that was in there
may compromise sources and methods and
names of people who help and it's just
totally irresponsible
can you assure the American people that
none of the documents discovered in your
garage or at your old office compromised
sources or methods or U.S intelligence
I've been advised by the council but the
justice department make that decision
they also saw you they'll comment on
former president Trump and so at the
very least because look here's what they
were showing they wish you guys were
showing on television
things lying on the ground and said top
secret National you know code word and
the difference is every single solitary
thing I've been asked to have done
voluntarily they're trying to make a
comparison
what there's degrees there
responsibility that are they can be
significant degrees if responsible
so his defense is look there's different
degrees of responsibility and that's
true
but the difference agrees all favor
Trump
Trump had the right to declassify any
documents he wanted he didn't have to
follow any particular procedure to do it
he could have done it in his head the
president of the United States is not
responsible to any bureaucrat when it
comes to declassifying documents
Joe Biden when he took those documents
did not have any such right
so the different degrees of
responsibility here is Joe Biden had a
far greater responsibility to handle
these documents with care and he
violated that responsibility in a far
more egregious way
and he knows it that's why even Joe
Biden who doesn't remember what ended up
was was impelled to answer at the top of
that question he said uh I've been
advised by the council not to say
anything because I obviously they've got
me dead to rights I doubt anything is
going to happen as a result of it
I doubt he's going to be held to account
I'm sure we're going to see more of this
corruption from the Democrats because
when you don't punish bad behavior then
you're going to get more of it
but he's at least admitting
at least implicitly
that what he did was a lot worse
speaking of leaders there is a kid
he went a little bit viral over the
weekend I want to make him go much more
viral I am so impressed with this kid
he was a freshman at a liberal High
School
and
I'm sure that his school is a lot like
your school and I'm sure that his school
is a lot like schools all around the
country
liberal uh
racist sexist in in all the opposite
ways that that we're told that the
public institutions are
and he said enough and he showed up to a
school board and he gave an oratory
worthy of at least getting him elected
to congress if not president already at
the age of 14. take a listen
hi my name is Brad Taylor and I just
finished my freshman year at rhs I've
been a part of District 106 schools now
for 10 years and I'm going to give you a
glimpse today of what's actually going
on inside these schools despite the
board's attempt to deny it district 196
schools are quickly becoming a place
where promoting activism is actually
more important than promoting education
I'll take
I'll take you back to my first day at
rhs this fall the principal came out and
gave us a heartfelt speech about
equality and standing together
he began to list countless races such as
Latino Asian expressing how much they
matter and how important they are but
never once did he mention a race or
identity that reflects me or half the
kids that were in the class
my honors government teacher I'm not
going to say his name but he's mentioned
that Democrats care more about all
people while Republicans only care about
themselves
and he's also inferred to us that
socialism is better than democracy he
even had a statue he had a statue of a
socialist leader in his classroom I've
been approached by multiple teachers who
have told me in private that they just
want to say that they agree with me and
they support me standing up but they
can't say it in front of the class for
fear of being
disciplined by the administration in
some way or losing their jobs now due to
all these instances I've mentioned and
many more that I can't fit in this
five-minute speech I've decided to leave
this district and continue school on a
private Christian School online but I
will never stop believing that everybody
has value no matter their skin color or
personal beliefs and it's a shame that
you're not going to be able to say that
I was an alumni of rhs in District 196.
thank you
preach
for I I what is he 15 he just finished
his freshman year in high school I guess
it's a little too young for congress but
let me know when you're ready to run kid
I can't wait to donate I can't wait to
go vote
beautiful that that kid showing more
clarity and maturity
and courage
then any and not only any other student
at the school any teacher at the school
he's saying these teachers come up to me
they say you're right I agree with you
but I don't want to lose my job
how sad is that you'll say Hey you 15
year old thanks for doing what I a grown
adult am unwilling to do
love it
and it presents a political opportunity
for republicans
we have control of a lot of states
around the country right now this is a
great opportunity to push school choice
and why should we push school choice
because the Democrats rely on the
schools as a major Power Center
school choice is the easiest way to
weaken their grip on that power and it's
a very powerful Power Center because
classrooms are crystal balls that show
you what your country is going to look
like in 20 years shapes the very
malleable minds of little kids
school choice is the biggest threat to
that
I've been mentioning it in my new state
of Tennessee which I love so much this
would be a great opportunity the
governor campaigned on school choice
he's obviously very supportive of it
we've got I don't know like three
Democrats in the whole legislature the
the Republicans outnumber the Democrats
three to one four to one in the house in
the Senate let's get it done guys this
is a great opportunity you have to be on
the offense or you will be on the
defense it's like a business anyone
who's ever run a business or worked for
a business for that matter will know
that a business is either growing or
dying
businesses don't just stay the same
though it doesn't work that way
you've got to be growing or dying you've
got to be moving forward or you're going
to be pushed backward
so let's do it while we've got power
let's just put that pedal to the metal
and let's give more kids the opportunity
that this young man has
to go pursue more edifying educational
opportunities and
perhaps even more important weaken the
Stranglehold of these crazy libs that
they have on public education so that we
can
create better schools in the future so
that we can go back get a little more
power in public education
and turn it toward the good the true and
the Beautiful not the ugly the false and
the wicked as it is now speaking of
young people
really disturbing story from Paris
Hilton
I haven't thought about Paris Hilton in
a long time it's been Paris Hilton I
guess she was sort of eclipsed by Kim
Kardashian and Kim Kardashian continues
to have a bad effect on her and on the
culture because Kim Kardashian
apparently encouraged Paris Hilton to
engage in IVF and IVF is a controversial
issue even among pro-lifers because many
people who oppose abortion who are
pro-life they will still be in favor of
IVF and one of the reasons for this is
that there are many people out there who
would not have their children without
IVF and so they say well if this process
gave me my child whom I love so then it
has to be a good process
and no one is doubting that your child
is great and that you having a child is
a great thing
but good ends do not justify immoral
means we're not machiavellians here
we're not utilitarians here we're not
consequentialists here we're
conservatives we believe that that the
morality of actions depends upon the
action itself
and in this case the way that Paris
Hilton has done it really shows you how
morally problematic IVF is because Paris
Hilton now has 20 children
I don't think she has any children that
have been born but she has 20 Frozen
embryos why does she have 20 why is she
so irresponsibly created 20 unique human
beings and then just shove them all in a
freezer well because she keeps getting
boys
and she don't want boys
she wants girls
so she's just going to keep trying IVF
she's got unlimited money so she's just
going to engage in IVF until she gets a
girl and the doctors I think are more
than happy to do it it's a very
expensive process
doctors are more than happy to trans the
kids it's a very expensive process the
doctors are more than happy to engage in
IVF it'll make them a lot of money
so who knows that maybe Paris will get
25 of her sons frozen forever for 30 or
35 until she gets a girl she says
she's waiting for that girl now
obviously if it were reversed and you
saw someone say yeah I'm putting all the
girls in a freezer until I get a boy I
really want a boy you'd have the
feminists screaming and crying and say
this is sexist and terrible and Eugenics
and but but because it's a boy and boys
are are castigated by the culture that
they don't want to say that these boys
are toxic you know the masculinity is
evil and toxic we have to get rid of it
that is really evil stuff
and why is she doing IVF in the first
place she says I'm just so scared
I think again leading back to Provo of
being in a doctor's office all of that
the shots the IVs that they put in she
says she was she was traumatized when
she was in a room when a woman was
giving birth when she was doing her
reality TV show The Simple Life
so it's not even that she's saying she
doesn't want to give birth or try the
natural way
because of some medical condition or
because of some personal trauma it's
just because it seems kind of icky to
her just want to have to do it so she's
going to have it done in test tubes and
then she'll rent out the womb of some
poor woman and inject it into her and
then maybe then that woman will give
birth to her child but maybe she want it
off she just keeps getting boys she'll
probably just leave them in the freezer
forever
can anyone explain to me why this should
not be illegal
can anyone see I know that many people
are tempted to support IVF
especially if it's benefited you
personally or
a family member
does anybody seriously believe that this
is okay
that this is morally right that this is
morally acceptable at all
putting Souls on Ice real human beings
and for your own children because you
don't like boys imagine if one of these
boys is born and finds out wait my mom
put me in a freezer and created 20 of my
siblings because she doesn't like boys
that much what's that going to do to
people's minds
could you imagine that you're one of
Paris Hilton Sons you see this you read
about this
tell me that this should not be illegal
tell me that it would be authoritarian
or terrible or too too much use of big
government to say hey you're not allowed
to make a bunch of kids and then throw
them in a freezer forever no one I don't
think anyone can really do that it's
music Monday baby we got to get on over
to the member block uh Ben Davies has
given me a song that he he wants me to
throw all of my pop culture prowess onto
and I'm willing to do that we will see
you there if you're not a member why not
are you just one of those Hoy polloi out
there perusing this show on YouTube for
free you got to go to
dailywire.comwles use code Knowles at
checkout to get two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
oh